[Music]
hey
so uh
i'm ready if you still want to go to the
max
really yeah
i mean you were right
the only way through hard things is
together
would it help if we did 10 push-ups
before we go
it would help a lot
[Music]
oh my
hope you're hungry
you guys are the first to try the newest
addition to the max menu
screech's spaghetti burger oh
kevin hey
kevin
you look amazing thank you i've had some
work done
i have a wheel hmm
you know it's
a little weird but
great then i like screech
you guys remember the time that he got
struck by lightning and was psychic for
a week
and then you used his powers to cheat on
a midterm yeah
why didn't we go to like vegas or
stop the gulf war
hey you know i'm still mad that that
little do you beat me becoming miss
bayside
yeah me too
yeah
he was so funny
yeah
to screech
screech screech
say isn't she
charming
isn't he
[Music]
[Applause]
and now it's my duty
to present to you with pride
the very first mr
miss
bayside
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you